it's midnight
by the time Wong and his sister arrive
at the hospital this will be his home
for the next two weeks as doctors
prepare him for the surgery that could
cure or kill him when the mother now
the next day harm undergoes tests which
reveal that his condition is rapidly
deteriorating since I came into the
Khandala
we did a CT scan to see what was going
on inside his skull you can see that the
tumor has already invaded his brain
his left eye has completely gone and the
tumor has invaded his throat what you
can see here another symbol if it
continues to grow he would stop his
breathing and kill him he shall be
innocent you sure the CT scan provides
grim news for horn his tumors are slowly
strangling him Shibata Maiasaura yada
hazardous Sakuma is making it really
hard for him to sleep at the moment
today
relatives are allowed to prepare food
for patients at private hospitals so
huang's sister will cook for him
throughout his stay
be open to the client I'm hiding around
Phillipa phone these are these ultimate
easily
what do you want so when they gave me my
nose
the masala for the carnival Kannada
struggle it is he now
probably also don't think so there were
students I wasn't going to the solo when
I was a teenager I used to dream that
one would suddenly recover become a
normal man tall and handsome now I hope
that dream will come true as Indiana